[Musica]
allora buona sera a tutti mi chiamo
guglielmo ho 32 anni vivo a roma in una
casa bellissima la casa dei miei sogni
una casa che non mi sarei mai mai potuto
permettere se avessi seguito la mia
passione per il calcio ma che invece
sono riuscito ad acquistare con la mia
professione avvocato
ora per chi non lo sapesse l'anno scorso
ho avuto la fortuna di essere annoverato
tra i 100 avvocati under 40 più
influenti nel mondo
sto con letizia da tanto tempo tra un
mese faremo il nostro primo anniversario
e quando ho visto letizia la prima cosa
che ho fatto è stato perdere
completamente la testa ho perso anche il
mio posto in squadra perché suo padre
era il mio allenatore quindi
automaticamente ma poi è andato tutto
bene tutto quanto insomma è filato
liscio
ora in un mondo nel quale le persone non
sanno che cosa vogliono io sono stato
fortunato perché io sin da subito ho
capito cosa volessi dalla vita avevo un
sogno
io credo veramente che i sogni si
avverino
e credo anche che il sogno più bello che
io abbia mai fatto l'ho fatto occhi
aperti quando ho visto letizia la prima
volta e anche quando le tiziano ha fatto
il regalo più bello che secondo me un
uomo possa ricevere una settimana fa mi
ha reso papa
[Applauso]
mi chiamo guglielmo e tutto quello che
vi ho appena detto è una cazzata
e per quanto possa sembrare assurdo
magari per alcuni di voi la persona che
vi ho appena presentato non potrebbe mai
rendermi felice
ho scelto questo elenco di bugie apposta
perché ho detto sono tutti avvocato in
famiglia oppure rita per essere papà
magari può sembrare che sono innamorato
o sembra che sono onesto può sembrare
che sono felice sembrare o essere due
termini che secondo me sono
importantissimi facciamo un esperimento
adesso mi ripresento e cerco di dirvi la
verità mi chiamo guglielmo e non mi
sento più così giovane
perché ci sono già persone che hanno
dieci anni meno di me hanno fatto dieci
volte quello che ho fatto in tutta la
mia vita
stavo insieme a un ragazzo pazzesco
bellissimo perfetto e ora sono single
non ami il calcio mi annoiata morire non
ho un figlio o un cane affetto da
flatulenze e spesso mi sveglio la
mattina senza sapere minimamente che
cosa stia facendo della mia vita senza
sapere minimamente in che direzione mi
stia muovendo 0 e per quanto può essere
assurdo questa persona è quella che ha
più possibilità di rendermi felice
ora io vedo alcune persone hanno
iniziato a storcere la bocca appena
iniziato a dire determinate cose altri
che prima era un po straniti è stata
sulle palle questa versione vincente di
quegli anni adesso sono più distesi
sorridono della serie a grazie a 2
grazie a dio anche di un fallito perché
era preso un colpo tranquilli tranquilli
però torniamo un secondo a questi due
termini sembrare o essere qual è più
importante
io non credo che esista una risposta io
non credo che dall'alto qualcuno ti
giudichi se scegli di agire in un modo o
in un altro non e non esiste un bene o
un male
se parliamo del nostro bene del nostro
male faccio un esempio
ora un po di anni fa una mia prozia
venne da me e mi regalò un suo tool per
da utilizzare all'interno di uno dei
miei video perché qualora non lo sapeste
io faccio intrattenimento online su
youtube
ok per chi non sapesse cosa non tube è
una specie di palla di capelli un
cespuglio di roba morta fondamentalmente
che capisci chi in testa orribile
specialmente se pensi che tua zia l'ha
indossato in tenera età
ora io ovviamente ho finto di essere
contentissimo di aver ricevuto questo
regalo sembravo sembravo felice e non è
stato sbagliato non mi sono pentito
perché il mio sembrare qualcosa che non
erano è permesso di non mortificare mia
zia
magari ci ha avvicinato in un certo
senso
ora io mia zia la porto nel cuore e se
voglio la porta in testa
secondo me dobbiamo fare tutti quanti
chiarezza su questa cosa dovremmo tutti
quanti renderci conto che a un certo
punto della nostra vita
esistono questi due termini sulla
bilancia sembrare o essere io sono
sembrato guglielmo tanto tanto tanto
tempo e più sembravo guglielmo più
volevo essere guglielmo errato un
momento in cui avevo questa esigenza
così forte che volevo fare come san
francesco
volevo accettare cercare guadagnare la
mia nudità e mostrarla al mondo nessuno
gli aveva detto quanto sarebbe stato
difficile togliere ogni singolo strato
togliere ogni singolo filtro che la
società in realtà ti vuole trattenere
addosso
c'è un termine che secondo me spiega
perfettamente questa azione rimuovere
delle vesti che fanno stare bene
gli altri quelli tranquillizzano gli
rasserenano ma che ti soffocano come un
maglione a collo alto ferragosto si
chiama coming out e io di coming out non
ho fatto uno ha fatti tanti e credo che
ognuno dovrebbe farne almeno uno nella
vita per stare bene
il mio il mio primo coming out l'ho
fatto con la mia nascita
partiamo da questo cioè in egitto di
pensavo di aver fatto tutto quanto in
regola pazzeschi per sembrava sembrava
non dovesse nascere invece eccomi qui
sembrava che non avrebbero avuto un
figlio invece ciao mamma ciao papà c'è
un video quindi lo vedranno spero il mio
secondo coming out è avvenuto quella
loro separazione
ora sembrava che la separazione tra due
genitori dovesse devastare un bambino
c'era una compagnetta una mia compagna
delle elementari che sta vivendo la mia
stessa situazione ok io così tante
lacrime non le ho viste manco non lo so
un concerto di justin bieber queste cose
qui quando mia mamma
i miei nonni vennero da me a dirmi ci
stiamo separando ci andiamo via
io mi sono messo a correre per il
giardino felicissimo sì dài torniamo a
roma bellissimo le famiglie sembrano
felici non è detto che sempre lo siano
davvero un altro coming out e l'ho fatto
non so con l'università sembrava che
dovessi seguire quelle che erano le orme
di tutta quanta mia famiglia
giurisprudenza poi diventi avvocato come
il nonno la mamma la cugina lo zio e il
prozio se come pure il mio cane cia una
laurea in giurisprudenza e non lo so
ancora
invece mi sono aperto un account su
youtube che sembrava non avrebbe portato
da nessuna parte
e invece è permesso di trovare una mia
voce di ascoltare la voce di tante
persone che mi hanno arricchito di
accedere al cinema alla tv all'editoria
alla radio poi uno dei miei preferiti
sembrava che sarei dovuto rimanere per
sempre con questa mia compagna di banco
che mi sarei dovuto fidanzare con questa
mia compagna di banco
e invece volevo fidanzarmi con suo
cugino
quindi io io credo che ognuno di noi
debba vivere la propria vita cioè
proprio come meglio crede nel rispetto
di se stessi e degli altri e poi lo so
lo so il mare della vita non è calmo per
tutti può arrivare
un'onda anomala all'improvviso che non
puoi prevedere che ti travolge
completamente è l'unica cosa che ci
rimane sono le nostre scelte
una tavola da surf
ok più o meno larga con la quale abbiamo
più o meno dimestichezza che alcuni di
noi non sanno prendere tra le mani altri
non hanno nemmeno il coraggio di mettere
sotto braccio e questo mare dove di
gente che a fatica cerca di rimanerci in
bilico altri che ci provano e cadono e
poi altri ancora non si sa come beccano
l'onda perfetta e servano fine arriva si
girano e si chiedono come sia possibile
che qualcun altro si sia bagnato senza
domandarsi minimamente che tipo di mare
abbiano incontrato e tempo abbiano
incontrato se abbiano ricevuto la stessa
tavola
ora io faccio questa metafora non tanto
per dirvi quanto secondo me sia
importante arrivare ad aggiungere arriva
asciutti ma quanto sia importante e
fondamentale fare di tutto per arrivarci
ne ho parlato di questa tavola che
rappresenta le nostre scelte e noi ne
abbiamo sempre una legata al polso
non importa la situazione noi sotto
braccio
abbiamo la possibilità di scegliere un
potere enorme
sembrare può essere virare a destra oa
sinistra con questa benedetta tavola io
ho visto persone che sono sembrate se
stesse per una vita intera hanno finto
di amare chi non amavano hanno finto di
studiare non studiavano hanno finto di
essere genitori felici non lo erano
hanno finto di amare un sesso che non
amavano hanno finto di appartenere un
genere che non gli apparteneva hanno
finto di essere uomini mariti amati e
rispettati hanno finto di essere donne
mogli amate e rispettate il mare delle
scelte è pieno dei loro cadaveri
naufraghi che si sono lasciati annegare
per paura di scontentare qualcuno
deludere qualcun altro per paura delle
conseguenze
ora non c'è tempo non possiamo parlare
delle conseguenze io credo che però
ognuno possa immaginare le conseguenze
delle proprie azioni
vorrei finire però facendo una
considerazione
una considerazione che secondo me è a
monte di tutto
sapete quanti ragazzi si tolgono la vita
perchè non riescono a essere se stessi
tanti troppi
noi abbiamo una sola vita
abbiamo la possibilità di scegliere
anche quando questi sembrano molto
limitate però dovremmo tutti quanti
porci una sola domanda quando a
scegliere per noi sono gli altri ne vale
davvero la pena
grazie
[Applauso]